hot and dry weather in southern
california is fueling a dangerous
out-of-control wildfire it has burned
more than 30 square miles
and destroyed at least one home about 70
miles east of los angeles
carter evans is near the scene in cherry
valley california carter good morning
well so far almost 8 000 people have
been evacuated you can look over my
shoulder see the flames glowing in the
night sky here the good news the wind
is not blowing right now but fighting a
fire in the age of covid and keeping
everyone safe
is proving challenging flames continue
to tear through trees and dry brush on
hillsides and riverside county
as winds picked up giving the apple fire
new life
given the fuel given the weather given
the topography
and where this is going this fire is not
going to stop tonight
as of late sunday only a small number of
the thousands under evacuation orders
have come to this red cross shelter
perhaps unaware they'll be given hotel
vouchers
folks that are not taking advantage of
it because they're
obviously concerned about cobit 19. we
have measures in place for that we plan
for this months ahead
as the fire moved through rough terrain
sunday afternoon
the battle turned primarily into an air
assault as temperatures
chopped 90 degrees over the weekend the
fire headed towards
homes and has not let up at least one
was destroyed
fixed wing aircraft dropped fire
retardant joined by water dropping
helicopters
and firefighters on the ground worked to
clear brush so one time they had like 40
fire trucks up here
so there was a fire truck like every
other house
this is the first major wildfire in
southern california since the pandemic
began
just one more concern for people living
here i'm picking up my mom
and my kids and we have to like move
them out of the house
you know we just praying for the best
now this fire actually started as two
fires that merged into one the good news
they are making some progress
it's about five percent contained right
now and both fires
are being investigated for arson eureka
carter thank you